[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 15 avril
40 % des moins de 34 ans ne se sont pas
déplacés aux urnes au premier tour de la
présidentielle reste est essentiellement
voter pour jean luc mélenchon
que vont faire les jeunes pour le
deuxième tour nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des étudiants de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
dans les territoires ruraux et les
quartiers populaires yvelinois la
tendance est similaire le choix
contestataires avec en tête le
rassemblement national d'un côté et de
l'autre la france insoumise si les
petites communes voteront encore pour
marine le pen comment les électeurs des
quartiers se positionneront si le 24
avril reportage à trappes et puis comme
tous les vendredis nos idées de sorties
dans les yvelines pour le pour les
prochains jours avec le week-end
prolongé de pâques qui se profile et le
sais tu ce week-end qui est de retour en
plateau et qui dit retour en plateau d'i
retour de mon acolyte du vendredi
bixente mayence insisté ban bonjour
bixente voirie je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver ou de nouvelles aventures
alors pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent
pas vous êtes mon monsieur loisirs dans
à cette émission vous nous donner chaque
semaine leur envie de sortir avec votre
sélection quels sont les suggestions du
jour bixente arriverez vous avez
commencé à en parler aujourd'hui
rendez-vous avec les lapins et cloches
et les chocolats pour un programme tout
autour de pâques on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure ce sera dans la deuxième partie
de cette édition dans le sahtu ce
week-end
mais petit retour en arrière pour
débuter cette émission avec le résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines quelles sont les informations à
retenir justin brasier vous résume le
tout en 78 secondes
[Musique]
dès lundi la campagne présidentielle de
l'entre-deux-tours été lancé le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle verra
s'opposer emmanuel macron arrivé en tête
également dans le département à marine
le pen plusieurs meetings sont
organisées malgré son ancrage sur le
territoire valérie pécresse est arrivé
en cinquième position dans les yvelines
l'acm polluées sur 14 km par une arme
blanche non identifiée
repéré au niveau de ben cours et
méricourt la pollution a été déportée
par le courant une vingtaine de pompiers
a été mobilisée pour identifier son
origine et tenter d'éliminer la
pollution
après l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines l'année dernière d'autres
communes du département ont décidé
d'adopter la trottinette électrique une
expérimentation est en cours à chevreuse
et saint rémy les chevreuse à
saint-cyr-l'ecole 23 stations seront en
service et le 19 avril des statuts du
château de versailles restaurer à
mantes-la-jolie elles ont été
délocalisées dans les anciens locaux de
l'entreprise dunlopillo le chantier de
restauration devraient durer 18 mois il
sera prochainement ouvert aux visiteurs
et puis côté loisirs encore une semaine
pour participer au concours numérique
des archives départementales est des
yvelines l'énigme la dame aux faucons
objectif retrouver son identité en
consultant des documents d'archivés
thème de l'année le moyen-âge
[Musique]
et c'était l'actualité à la une de ce 78
secondes le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui se profile avec une
incertitude où vont aller les voix des
français qui ont voté pour les candidats
éliminés au premier tour dans les
yvelines jean luc mélenchon a pour
rappel terminé deuxième et pour elle a
terminé deuxième de ce scrutin dans les
yvelines avec près de 23% des suffrages
grâce au vote des quartiers populaires
est notamment dans la ville de trappes
où les électeurs l'ont placé largement
en tête le reportage de mélanie poker
nicolas landry et patrick jacques de
dixmude
et vers qui les 6000 électeurs
trappistes de jean luc mélenchon se
tourneront second tour le 10 avril
dernier la ville a vu le candidat la
france insoumise arrivé en tête avec 60%
des suffrages ce mercredi matin sur le
marché les trappistes sont partagés vous
êtes toujours je pense pas que je vais
voter parce que je vais pas voter nuit
macro ni le punch et au milieu mais je
vais réfléchir monsieur macron nous à
promet plein de choses mais
malheureusement
comme on dit on n'a rien on a rien qui a
été caractérisée pour pour l'instant on
va essayer de voter deuxième tour
espérant bien qu'il va et va tenir ses
promesses pour le second tour je compte
pas voté pour moi est ce que macro n'est
pas plus pire que marine le pen j'en
viens à me poser cette question donc du
coup
je slame franchement ça m'enchante pas
du tout que mc oui pour repasser une
deuxième fois parce que je pense que ces
cinq années qu'on a vécu sous son mandat
sincèrement c'était la catastrophe et
sincèrement je me dis pourquoi pas
marine le pen alors dans ces cas là pour
certains électeurs le regard est déjà
tourné vers les prochains scrutins les
élections législatives des 12 et 19 juin
prochains on aimerait qu après les
législatives les députés apparaissent au
mois de juin que mélenchon près la
france a soumis se prennent une place
prépondérante pour aider les gens au
niveau du social on a un objectif
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir à l'assemblée
nationale un groupe qui soit et combatif
comme il l'a été avec 16 députés mais
cette fois ci avec l'avantagé du nombre
et une capacité de blocage c'est ça que
nous cherchons à avoir aujourd'hui une
cohabitation jean luc mélenchon a aussi
réalisé un bon score dans les villes
populaires comme mantes-la-jolie manque
la ville s'est retrouvée chanteloup les
vignes ou encore la verrière dès le 10
avril la france est soumise n'a pas
appelé à voter pour emmanuel macro mais
a souhaité qu'aucune voile naya marine
le pen
avec un deuxième tour qui se profile le
24 avril prochain pour rappel au premier
tour les jeunes ont largement voté
justement pour jean luc mélenchon ou se
sont tout simplement abstenus 42 % des
18-24 ans ne se sont pas déplacés aux
urnes que vont ils faire le 24 avril
mathilde franco est allé interroger
quelques étudiants devant l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
34% c'est le pourcentage des 18 24 ans
qui ont donné leurs voix au candidat de
la france un soumise à quelques jours du
second tour nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre pour savoir ce qu'ils comptent
faire vu pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'important j'irai voter mais je pense
blanc parce qu' aucun des deux candidats
qui m'intéresse je pense que je voterai
pour macron pour commencer par et
l'extrême droite et
mais j'ai quand même peur parce que je
pense que c'est mort à une
perte une mauvaise surprise cette année
a priori je pense que je vais m'abstenir
parce que je suis ni en faveur de marine
le pen ou de emmanuel macron donc pour
pas jouer le jeu des barrages pense que
je vais m'abstenir je compte n'est pas
donné de voir à l'extrême droite et
faire blocus est votée macro face à la
hausse du score du rassemblement
national mais aussi des voix attribué à
eric zemmour les jeunes se montrent
plutôt inquiets bon je suis personne
noire et c'est vrai que quand on regarde
même zemmour cas que 7% des voix s'est
tendue quand même
donc oui ça me fait peur déjà avec
zemmour qui est dé diaboliser un peu
marine le pen et on a un peu oublié
vraiment l'essentiel autour de sa
personne même si c'est vrai qu'elle
donne une image un peu plus ouverte mais
c'est quand même c'est le c'est
l'héritage de son papa donc faut pas
faut pas se leurrer sur certains sur
certains points notamment tout ce qui
est des nouveaux bus choqué que marine
le pen en fait les gens ils ont oublié
que c'était l'extrême droite et c'est
vrai que ça me choque ac après on s'en
douter qu'elle allait passer au second
tour c'est quand même signe d'une montée
d'une extrémisation par rapport au
racisme à l'anti migration etc oui
forcément ça me fait peur pour l'avenir
partout en france les étudiants élèvent
leur voix et bloque les universités ils
ne veulent pas choisir une nouvelle fois
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
dans le département les voies pour
marine le pen n'ont que très légèrement
augmenté entre 2017 et aujourd'hui mais
dans certaines communes rurales ancrée
rassemblement national depuis plusieurs
années les résultats sont en hausse
notable pouvoir d'achat votre
contestataires immigration matic de
franck ou et céline chante céline
charles sont allés à la rencontre de ses
électeurs
cinq ans plus tard la fiche est la même
emmanuel macron et marine le pen se
retrouve de nouveau face à face dans les
yvelines c'est le rassemblement national
la gagne un petit point au premier tour
de la présidentielle par rapport à 2010
est dans les communes rurales situées au
nord du département et à l'extrême sud
les résultats sont en hausse par exemple
à guîtres en cours marine le pen arrive
en tête avec 39 points 67 % des
suffrages c'est quatre points de plus
qu'en 2017 moi je suis adhérent j'ai été
chez marine le pen il ya longtemps en
2008 et donc du coup
j'aimerais bien que marine le pen un
jour elle passe mais moi je pense
qu'elle passera jamais contre marion
maréchal et passera
10 15 20 ans ça arrivera mais la france
a sera descendu bien bas j'ai voté pour
marine le pen parce que elle est enfin
je saisis des sons sont assez proches
des miennes je pense qu'elle va redonner
un petit peu de pouvoir d'achat aux gens
donc ça ça me paraît important
elle est allée contre l'immigration je
partage un petit peu ses idées je trouve
que voilà il y en a suffisamment ici en
france certains yvelinois attendent
encore le débat de l'entre-deux tours
pour se décider d'autres ont déjà fait
leur choix ce sera marine le pen pour
contrer emmanuel macron marine le pen
parce que je ne crois pas en ma
compassion ou la politique la politique
me dérange c'est un personnage qui est
détestable pour moi j'attends le débat
parce que monsieur macro à nous
présenter pour voir ce qui va défendre
et madame le pen savoir si elle va mieux
se débrouiller qu' il ya cinq ans
messieurs macron il veut détruire la
france il veut détruire les petits
villages il veut détruire les
départements il mais l'écrire la france
pour l'europe qu'il agit si le
rassemblement national progresse dans
les yvelines avec plus de 3000 suffrages
supplémentaires par rapport à 2010 est
sa candidate n'arrive en tête que dans
quarante et une des communes contre 56
il ya cinq ans
il est justement question de marine le
pen et de l'une de ses propositions de
campagne dans notre rubrique légal
checking chaque vendredi décryptage de
l'actualité sur tv 78,7 avec raphaël
mata duvignau du collectif des
surligneurs
marine le pen soutient dans son
programme électoral et a récemment
rappelé sa composition que la cour de
justice de l'union européenne impose aux
états membres d'aménager le temps de
travail des militaires et ce qu'importe
les circonstances la candidate et rennes
vise en effet une décision de 2021 qui
interprète une directive européenne sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail mais
en réalité la rai est bien plus nuancées
il était question en effet du temps de
travail des militaires mais en période
de paix et non en réel de guerre les
surligneurs avait déjà il ya à peu près
un an détaillé les grands principes de
cette décision en effet la cour de
luxembourg n'a jamais entendu porté
atteinte aux intérêts nationaux des
états membres mais seulement concilier
l'intérêt de la nation d'une part et le
droit en l'occurrence des salariés
d'autre part car les soldats
professionnels rappelons le sont aussi
des salariés presque comme les autres
alors pour préserver cet équilibre la
cour précise clairement qu'elle
n'applique pas la directive sur le temps
de travail aux militaires en période de
guerre elle distingue ainsi
explicitement le travail du soldat en
balles normales et en période
exceptionnelle elle mentionne également
l'article 4 paragraphe 2 du traité sur
l'union européenne qui prévoit que
l'union respecte les fonctions
essentielles des états membres et
notamment la sécurité nationale ce qui
justifie encore plus insistants dessus
sa distinction entre temps normal est
temps de guerre la cour en tire donc la
conclusion que les temps de travail
maximum prévu par la directive
européenne ne s'applique pas si cela est
contraire à l'intérêt national or il est
évident qu'en temps de guerre les
militaires sont à l'entière disposition
de l'état linverse signifierait qu après
39 heures de travail nous sommes là
doivent se reposer où qu'ils soient et
qu'ils auraient droit par exemple à 11
heures de repos entre deux peines de
travail cela n'aurait aucun sens surtout
en cette période de guerre la cour de
justice n'a donc jamais entendu cela et
marine le pen en juriste de formation
calais devraient bien le savoir
aller le week-end de pâques débutent le
soleil est au rendez vous c'est l'heure
de sortir dans les yvelines
avec bixente n'a rien senti steban qui
je le sais est très pressé d'aller
chasser les oeufs en chocolat ce
week-end c'est pas qui bien évidemment
est le programme est chargé dans les
yvelines bichonne ses fruits puisque
après deux ans d'annulation au dernier
moment faute de kobe de la fête des
oeufs de la ferme de gally tout d'abord
célèbre son grand retour ce week-end
pour l'occasion les habitudes sont
bouleversés et ce n'est ce n'est non pas
un jour mais deux jours de festivités
autour de la chasse aux oeufs et de
nombreuses autres animations benjamin
responsable de la ferme des animaux nous
en dit plus
[Musique]
ce week-end ici à la femme de galion à
faire ce qu'on appelle à la chasse aux
oeufs donc en fait on va accueillir les
familles qui vont venir les enfants ou
venir chercher les cons aura mis dans
l'est dans les prés au préalable et en
échange c'est cela du coup ils vont
ils vont pouvoir avoir des oeufs en
chocolat
la fête des oeufs c'est vraiment pour
marquer le printemps du coup au
printemps c'est un peu la renaissance il
ya des naissances du coup d'agneau de
chevreau des poussins des oiseaux voilà
les feuilles qui reviennent nous voir un
peu marquer le coup lors de cette fête
et c'est aussi l'occasion où on va
notamment tondre les moutons donc on va
récupérer la laine et du coup on va
faire des activités avec les enfants
autour notamment de la laine mais aussi
des nids de pour les oiseaux des choses
comme ça des petites plantations voilà
[Musique]
mais après deux ans de collines ou à
chaque fois on a préparé notre fête et
au dernier moment on n'a pas pu la faire
on est un peu frustré de pas la faire là
on est on est remonté à bloc pour
pouvoir accueillir tout le monde et on
est on est vraiment content de pouvoir
enfin la sphère du coup on est tellement
contents on considère qu'on a à faire
sur deux jours et pas sur une journée
comme avant
une petite surprise qu'on lâche comme ça
c'est que on a
des petits chamallows que les gens vont
pouvoir venir et enrobés de chocolat on
a une petite fontaine en chocolat voilà
c'est la petite surprise
mais grégory il n'y a pas que la fête
des oeufs de la ferme de gally ce week
end autres chasses sont programmées dans
le département et pour nous en dire plus
juste in brazil nous a rejoint en
plateau bonjour bonjour le ste donc oui
des chasses aux oeufs comme vous l'avez
dit on aura un peu partout n'hésitez pas
à vous renseigner personnellement je
vous ai fait un top 3 avec des chasses
aux oeufs ou il ya des événements des
petites choses à côté alors vous me
direz grégory et bixente qu'est laquelle
de ces idées vous donne le plus envie
c'est donc pas que ça évitera a déjà au
château de breteuil à choisel yara il y
aura dix mille oeufs à retrouver dans le
domaine de deux hectares à des jeux de
couleurs à ramasser et à échanger donc à
la fin contre à du chocolat bien sûr à
la clé également des livres de contes de
charles de paix charles perrault pardon
ce sera pour les plus chanceux qui
auront trouvé il y aura 3 e en eau rare
à trouver sur le site et vous pourrez
participer à un atelier à côté de ça
pour décorer des ou encore créer des
nids voilà vous pouvez profiter
également de visiter le château ou de
vous de découvrir les scènes des contes
de perrault et ça se passera en tout cas
le week-end de pâques les 17 et 18 avril
de 11h30 à 17h et pas besoin de réserver
pour venir à à l'événement donc ça
c'était pour le château de breteuil nous
vous nous avez dit vous avez dit que
vous donneriez trois idées justine ou
pour nous chasser les ensuite exactement
donc en deuxième idée on peut également
faire un tour à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet c'est un rendez vous
familial qui vous est proposé pareil en
ici des oeufs colorés seront à ramasser
pour être échangé contre du vrai
chocolat parce qu'on adore le chocolat
ce que j'ai bien aimé c'est qu'ils ont
adapté finalement la fête à la ferme
puisque donc il y aura des ateliers
aussi à côté mais qui seront sur le
thème des épreuves ludiques auprès des
animaux par exemple ou la fabrication
panier en décoration il y aura le foin
ou encore la laine donc ça c'est plutôt
sympathique à côté vous pouvez profiter
bien sûr des activités habituelles et
tours en calèche les explications sur la
traite des vaches ou encore la
nourrissage des animaux et tout ça se
passera les 16 17 et 18 avril de 14
heures à 18 heures et si jamais vous et
l'événement ce week end l'opération est
reconduite du 23 avril au 4 mai avec en
plus une chasse aux oeufs 2.0 à l'aide
d'un détecteur de métaux
et enfin troisième idée ce dimanche de
pâques atteint attendra également les
personnes à la maison elsa triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines une
chasse aux oeufs qui s'adresse donc aux
enfants de 3 à 12 ans avec à la clé
encore des chocolats et là tant donné
voilà nekili acquis les idées retenues
précédemment j'imagine qu'il n'y aura
pas qu'une chasse aux 2 prévus sur place
à d'autres choses oui oui il ya deux
choses 1 voilà je vous ai dit il ya des
petites choses à côté le petit plus ce
sera des spectacles qui vont venir
ponctué l'événement une danseuse va
déambuler dans le parc elle sera
enfermée dans une bulle donc ça promet
un peu quelque chose de positif
puisqu'elle sera aussi accompagné d'un
musicien et puis il y aura le spectacle
le musée d'art tout terrain d'henriette
et huguette donc ça c'est un spectacle
de musée qui vient peu à vous puisque
les artistes vous raconteront l'histoire
des grands tableaux et en tout cas
apprécié l'événement s'adresse à tous et
rendez vous pour celui là le dimanche 17
avril uniquement de 14 heures à 18
heures il faut par contre réservée cette
fois ci sur le site merci juste si vous
avez fait votre choix biche était bien
ça fait longtemps que je parlais à la
bergerie nationale de renvoyer de mon
côté alors peut-être que c'est une
petite journée complète là bas ça peut
être un vrai que toutes les
programmations toute la programmation où
nous avait donné justin parfait mois la
maison les à triolet aragon pour ne pas
être allé souvent sur place aussi ça
fait ça fait longtemps j'y suis allé une
fois pour un reportage donc ce serait
l'occasion de retourner avec des
performances en plus artistique donc
pourquoi pas couplées tout ça voilà pas
que c'est une bonne occasion vous l'avez
rappelé déguster du chocolat tout de
même
en cette matière mais szentes que vous
avez quelques conseil nous donner votre
mission c'est du chocolat mais il lui
noah forcément grégory cette fête
représente presque un quart de
l'activité annuelle des chocolatiers
rendez vous donc attendu et ça tombe
bien puisque à quelques kilomètres d'ici
se trouve une petite demeure un peu
féerique elle n'est pas en panne et pis
mais presque how dans la cabane de grimm
est un artisan chocolatier ouvert depuis
2014 même si en ce moment l'activité bat
son plein la gérante nous a ouvert les
portes de son magasin pour une petite
visite
regardez
[Musique]
le
nous nous trouvons à la cabane de grimau
dans une chocolaterie en pleine
préparation des fêtes de pâques et pour
en parler avec nous cécile lefrançois
bonjour bonjour j'imagine qu'en ce
moment vous êtes à vous tourner à plein
régime pour préparer ces fêtes comment
ça se passe ces fêtes de pâques se
préparent en général très tôt après noël
parce que pâques est une
grand événement pour nous les
chocolatiers dans l'année c'est le
deuxième pour un très honnête donc ça
représente 20 % de notre activité à peu
près et du coup il faut pas faiblir
sortie de noël effectivement on
s'attaque à pâques au prototype et puis
ensuite à la production voilà si cela
vous dit je propose qu'on aille voir ce
que vous nous proposez et bain avec
plaisir donc cette année comme tous les
ans d'ailleurs on essaye de définir un
thème qui sortent un petit peu des
sentiers battus
la cloche les lapins et des poules cette
année on a choisi aladin comme thème est
donc on
voilà on a décliné les personnages les
sujets autour de ce thème de la balade
et bien c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah c'est ici que se trouve le gros de
votre production exactement en tout cas
tous les sujets de thématiques donc
autour d'aladdin effectivement se
retrouvent ici
voilà donc vous avez l'oeuf mille et une
nuits ici qui ressemble à un mandala un
petit peu et donc qui rappelle un peu ce
côté exotique vous avez l'éléphant le
califat voilà donc une assez grosse
pièce effectivement
[Musique]
voilà et puis je vois le singe voilà le
petit hamou djellit le perroquet yago
perroquet aussi la loi exactement la
lampe merveilleuse voilà vous avez le
tapis volant avec son petit dromadaires
donc qu'est-ce qu'il fonctionne qu est
ce qui fait la tendance un peu en ce
moment alors la tendance cette année
c'est vrai qu' on est un petit peu moins
sur les sujets classiques et vraiment il
ya un engouement sur ces sujets un peu
originaux un peu exotique voilà qui
rappelle le voyage pense que les gens
ont le vent et donc ils se tournent
beaucoup vers ces sujets là et il ya une
pièce maîtresse 7 po nationaux oui qui
se trouve justice il exactement
la caverne aux merveilles la caverne
d'aladdin la caverne qui dans lequel
dans laquelle aladin a trouvé sa petite
lampe merveilleuse et le génie qui lui
est associée on retrouve sur cette pièce
le tapis volant est évidemment le trésor
et puis cette fameuse caverne donc c'est
un vrai travail d'orfèvre risque elle a
été commandée cette pièce elle n'a pas
encore été commandée mais mais on a bon
espoir qu'elle le soit en tout cas moi
je vais réfléchir alors
[Musique]
mais
et donc on se trouve juste devant le
laboratoire oui tout à fait on a la
chance ici d'avoir le laboratoire
complètement
lle en lien avec la boutique en tout cas
est donc un retour client direct un
échange entre vraiment la production et
la boutique c'est ça qui est intéressant
ici
[Musique]
ceci vous est ouverte depuis 2014 et
forcément la cabane de grimm ça nous
évoque un peu les comptes quelle est
l'histoire de ce magasin alors moi je
suis
une grande enfant je suis resté un grand
enfant en tout cas passionné des contes
pour enfants et
notamment des contes des frères grimm
donc j'ai voulu rendre hommage à
à ces écrivains
compteur en tout cas
et voilà donc on on a créé cette
boutique vraiment sur ce thème là donc
sur les étagères vous retrouverez les
lutins des faits voilà donc un monde un
peu fantastique un peu magique et
et qu'il va bien je trouve donc depuis
huit ans maintenant vous occupez vous
atteler la craie et chocolats
confiseries et glace pour les petits et
les grands c'est ça tout à fait en
espérant que ça ravissent voilà les
petits et les grands oui en tout cas
pour pas que même en tout temps tout le
monde peut venir ici merci beaucoup sa
cible avant merci à vous
[Musique]
bon à bixente le défi est relevé du
chocolat yvelinois il ya le côté
féerique fantastique en plus donc tout
va bien est une bonne nouvelle peut en
amener une autre il ya le week-end de
pâques et week-end prolongé pour pour
pâques dans les prochains jours et à la
fin de la semaine prochaine les
yvelinois seront en vacances et les
vacances de printemps qui est débuteront
avec aussi des choses au programme
qu'avez vous à nous proposer de ce point
de vue là déjà tout d'abord un rendez
vous au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la saison suit
son cours et j'aimerais vous parler
d'une petite création artistique ça
s'appelle les hauts plateaux et c'est un
voyage au dessus des nuages proposé par
des acrobates un peu à la manière dont
brushing oise il s'envole sur des
trampolines pourra compter la victoire
de la vie sur la peur un spectacle créé
par le circassien mathurin bolze à
découvrir au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines le jeudi 21 et le
vendredi 22 avril à 20h30 qu'il ya des
activités aussi en extérieur avec le
beau temps s'il vous plaît quand même
les chaînes rouillées ce que vous aimez
la pêche grégory pas vraiment je pas
quelqu'un de très patient donc satisfait
force effectivement ça peut jouer parce
qu'ils ont en tout cas dans les villes
il ya plein de lieux où passer une
journée en famille ou entre amis avec un
petit pique nique par exemple j'ai
choisi de vous parler de la pisciculture
de villette à villette parce que c'est
un lieu plutôt sympa avec un élevage de
truites une boutique avec des produits
du terroir de la pêche en bassin pour
les plus jeunes ou en étant pour les
plus expérimentés surtout les plus
impatients et l'actu du moment c'est
l'arrivée de carpes koï élevé en france
vous pour vos petits étangs de jardin
c'est coloré c'est sympa il ya donc
largement de quoi passer une journée
remplie ou ne serait-ce qu'une demi
heure grégory puisque avec les petits
étant les deux truites vous pouvez même
si vous n'êtes pas patient en dix
minutes vous avez 4,8 et voulait ramener
chez vous on va essayer mais toutes les
informations en tout cas sur son lit on
sur le site pisciculture point fr qui
est bien le site de la pisciculture deux
villes est et non de la pisciculture en
général un grégory on termine cette
émission avec une idée pour les plus
jeunes de nos téléspectateurs oui les
vacances c'est l'occasion de découvrir
de nouvelles choses s'essayer à de
nouvelles pratiques pour les sportifs du
ce2 à la 6ème l'école des sports de
maisons laffitte propose des journées de
découverte du football gay de l'ultimate
du tchoukball plein de sports a plutôt
incroyable les inscriptions c'est
jusqu'au 21 avril ensuite plus
artistique un stage au musée de la toile
de jouy les 6 12 ans pourront s'essayer
à la teinture sur étoffes les mardi 26
et jeudi 28 avril inscription via le
mail qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
attention il va s'afficher le mail de
jouy en josas
et pour finir quelque chose d'un peu
plus insolites qui sort un peu du cadre
conventionnel habituel un stage au coeur
des cascades de cinéma c'est le cabaret
du bout des prêts à cerner la ville qui
propose cette initiation les 9 17 en ont
l'opportunité de rencontrer d'échanger
avec deux professionnels du métier les
25 26 et 27 avril avec même allé un
apprentissage de de quelques bases pour
réaliser sa première cascade de cinéma
et s'essayer à faire un peu le tom
cruise amateurs dont vois pas pourquoi
pas en plus avec le festival de cannes
qui va arriver donc il ya tous souhaité
cinématographique qui se profile merci
bixente c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission bon week end à vous bon
week-end prolongé de pâques s'ils
avaient aussi grand et bon week-end à
tous nos téléspectateurs l'information
locale qui reviendra mardi avec le
journal de la rédaction à partir de 19h
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]